I was hanging out at my nephew the other
day I was teaching him some life lessons
and then right in the middle my big
speech she goes Uncle Joe why are your
teeth all yellow well say that's because
Santa Claus isn't real
that's probably the main and we both had
a good cry that felt good
it's traumatic being a cop I'm still at
remote eyes from how I'm traumatized
right now I'm I'm still traumatized when
I was a child but I was seven years old
this is a true story I'd have my tonsils
taken out and when I woke up from my
tonsil surgery I was missing my two
front teeth they just took my teeth I
had him before didn't have him after
nobody told me nobody asked me I didn't
sign anything they just took my teeth
the doctors like they're a little loose
they're gonna come out anyway so we just
took him out for you and I was like I've
never heard of that policy in my why
don't you take my heart that's gonna go
bad at some point just pull that right
out of there I don't buy it I feel like
they were bored at the end of their
shift and they're like how funny if it
took this kids teeth out of his head
then the other doctor is like what are
you crazy it's tonsil surgery he's like
who cares he's seven he's a little [ __ ]
take his feet I couldn't believe it I
was like I twice did you I was crying
and spitting and I told my mother I was
like they took my teeth and she was like
well you're gonna get a visit from the
tooth fairy and I was like how bout a
visit from a lawyer how about that they
took my adenoids as well I even know
what an ADD no it is and I never will
because they were stolen from me when I
was seven years old they ransacked my
entire face then years later a few years
ago I'd have a pendous surgery at
appendicitis so I went and they knocked
you up for that first of all there's a
test to find out if you have
appendicitis it'll hurt in your upper
vagina area there's a tent that could be
anything what you do is you push in
it'll hurt and then when you release it
hurts twice as much everybody laughs
it's a real thing you can google it's
called rebound tenderness you can check
it out so I did it
and I had it so I went to the hospital
and I told the nurse it was a guy I said
sir I have appendicitis
I did the finger push test and then he
pushed in on my Bendix and I
like what are you doing and he was like
I'm testing you for appendicitis and I
was like you should test your hearing I
just told you I administered this test
already I have it you don't need special
male nurse fingers for this and then you
let go and I was like oh and he was like
that's appendicitis and I was like
that's what I told you one moment ago
and he was like you need surgery and I
was like that's what I'm doing here at
the surgery store that's why I mosey on
down to the surgery establishment then I
waited for the surgeon to come out she
was a woman she was really nice at first
she was like you have any questions
about the surgery and I was like as a
matter of fact I do
will you be removing any of my teeth
and then she said why would we remove
your teeth and I was like yeah why would
you remove my teeth that's what I'm
asking you lady and then she said no
we're not gonna remove your teeth and
then this [ __ ] she pushed in so you're
gonna hold that in and tell him
unconscious and she was like no and then
she was like wow she was like that's
appendicitis and I was like I'm on the
operating table I don't know why you
could have saved me for hours by taking
my word for it then they knocked me out
I woke up from the surgery of course I
checked for all my teeth wanted to make
sure no trust him I had all my teeth
successful surgery then I went to the
bathroom to urinate and discovered that
they shaved my pubic hair they just
always take a little extra I was like is
this a hospital or a frat house
I checked in the mirror to make sure
they enjoy any dicks on my face it
didn't even occur to me with like you
have any questions about the surgery
like what about my pubic hair he'd be
shaving my beard I think that's all I
took my teeth when I was seven I had no
pubic hair to offer them at that point
like this kids clean as a whistle he
moustashe before he got here
take his teeth as a penalty at least
with teeth is the tooth fairy you get a
few bucks but there's no pubic hair
fairy the Lu era I gotta go you guys are
great
[Applause]
you